Oh
all right let's go to punch make up now
today we are going to be trying a cold
duty black ops 3 bit Brandon beer called
black hops which makes sense a classic
American pale ale that is crisp white
and refreshing with tantalizing hop
aromas of pine and citrus fruit I
usually drink cider sometimes I'll drink
beer also add tend to steer towards the
spirits usually so he is not really my
forte I do love Guinness and dark ales
some variances in this for sure I think
it's going to taste like beer can I like
beer that's okay it says it's a pale ale
so I'm expecting I'm expecting something
crisp with a bit of a bit of a open
flavor to it people keep telling me I'm
going to come across a beer that I don't
mind and there are a couple not many
this might be it cold GD black ops 3
black ops might be my calling oh good
actually it's kind of good I think it's
a little citrusy
not bad it's it's a nice kind of bitter
e it's like kind of like it like it like
coffee flavor i want to say well yeah
it's gross despite it saying without the
harsh roast or bitter flavors you might
expect from a darkhel it's still like
tastes more like a dark L to me so if I
was at a bar that was serving different
beers this is probably the last be right
order really does look like coca-cola
it's like visiting an exact same way to
cook like coca-cola you hold on to the
light it looks like has the same time
transparency is coca-cola I don't know
if it's because it's ten-thirty in the
morning and I've just brushed my teeth
but I'm feeling like how taste is
Kentucky's hate it fits with what that's
really yucky it smells better than it
tastes ah that's just that's just awful
it's a bit of it's like it yeah it's
definitely like a rosti villa it's not
like a lot of it up it stops off a nice
enough but then like the finish is kind
of like not that great I can't say that
it reminds me of cod at all midnight
parallel is a very confusing name it
sounds like there to be this mess it
tastes horrible the more than I just
gets worse yeah I really like it I think
it's great I don't like you gets a crazy
this is a really good beer you can taste
the citrus to the start and then it just
gets like really like fighty and it
tastes like eating something rotten koj
Flacco's buy it today ah refreshing
you